hey guys what's up we have been thinking
a lot lately and we want to include
dragons in our videos so coming up is a
list of the six most powerful dragons
taken from live-action movies and
television yeah we know that our list
will not be the same as yours
but in this video we will include the
dragons kill list its powers the amount
of destruction that it has wrought upon
and surroundings and its measure of
strength by assessing the battles it had
with other monsters and even humans the
kinds of dragons that we will include
here are those that are soft and
blissful but the ones that are actually
full of fire inside and out we will
exclude Ghidorah however from this list
as he has been in too many rankings as
well as explanation videos let's give
him a rest for a while but there are a
couple of Japanese movie kaiju that are
included here and yeah they are very
powerful indeed so here goes the list at
number 6 we have drawn from Game of
Thrones the entry rank goes to Game of
Thrones drawn he is one of the three
dragons born in the waste lands beyond
Lazar along with a smaller brothers
Rhaegar and Viserion he can be
distinguished by his black and red
coloured scales and red black wings
he was also Daenerys personal mounts and
her loyal companion till her death had a
red keep sighs dragon was the size of a
kitten in the first season but grew
gradually with every passing season
ending up being the size of a whale
around 120 to 140 feet long with an
equally long wingspan destruction drove
on has immense physical strength and can
spit destructive streams of fire he can
also fly extremely high and had great
speeds he has enough firepower to
destroy King's Landing single-handedly
in a day kill count with all the bells
that he has been in including the Battle
of Winterfell beyond the wall against
the army of the Dead and King's Landing
drogon has thousands of human bodies on
his belt even though many of them are
zombies barrels drove on has a lot of
battles against humans White Walkers and
his own brother this area
his only vulnerabilities are against
scorpion arrows and also the eye Spears
thrown by the night King otherwise he
sweeps the floor clean against any other
opponent number five the bull dragon
from the 2002 reign of fire the bull
dragon is a highly evolved big fierce
dangerous prehistoric reptile which
serve as the main antagonist of the 2002
film rain of fire the dragons in the
rain of fire were around along with the
dinosaurs and world the apparent course
of their extinction the male is capable
of living for a very very long time and
maybe he is biologically immortal size
as seen in the movie most of the Dragons
were around 30 to 40 feet long but they
were all females the bull male however
was five to six times bigger the
wingspan on the bull dragon was 320 feet
it was as big as a 747 and there were
around a hundred 60 feet of wing behind
a dragon when he folded them back
destruction the dragon was the cause of
the destruction of major cities
worldwide and even modern weaponry
weren't enough to bring him down his
ability to breathe fire made him a
weapon of mass destruction and this is
the main reason he is on the number five
ranked kill count since he was the main
reason as to why humanity's civilization
came crumbling down along with all the
major cities around the world therefore
putting his kill count in the millions
barrels the only major barrels that he
has been in is against humanity and as
we have seen him easily destroy a convoy
of soldiers along with armored transport
as well as a tank without even getting a
scratch we can say that he easily took
the win although he was later killed in
the end by an explosive arrow shot into
his throat number four small from the
Hobbit trilogy small the fire Drake from
The Hobbit movies is probably one of the
most well known of all the Dragons on
this list for 171 years smoke hoarded
the lonely mountain stretches to himself
staying within the mountain until the
company of dwarves managed to enter the
Lonely Mountain and awaken him from his
high Bonet
sighs much has been debated about the
size of smoke in the Hobbit trilogy but
some put him in the range of a measly 60
to 70 feet long but other estimates
which we agree on put small around 200
feet long which is 60 meters destruction
smart was the last of the great dragons
of middle-earth he was responsible for
not only chasing the dwarves away from
Erebor but also the destruction of the
city of Dale and lady esketh as seen in
the movies kill count to estimate the
kill count of this dragon we first have
to know the populations of Dale Erebor
and as growth as stated by Stefan
Whitmore Erebor would have housed no
more than a hundred thousand wharves
Dale a small city would have had a
population of between 10,000 to 15,000
humans while lake town would only have
no more than a thousand therefore
assuming small 50% of Erebor Dale and
later as growth his skill car would be
somewhere between 50 and 60,000 barrels
Smaug has never bailed
any other larger monster like the early
ones on this list but he has faced
against the mighty armies of dwarves of
Erebor and humans wielding ballista
scorpion arrows he was only killed in
Lake town by Bart shooting an arrow at
his heart through an opening in his
scales and the number three comes dragon
storm from Transformers the last night
dragons tom is a beastly tree headed
transformer dragon a mighty combination
form of the legendary 12 Guardian
Knights of Cybertron who oppose
Quintessa and in the year 484 before
current era the Knights form dragon
storm for the first time at Marilyn's
request to drive off the immoral Saxon
from me Tanya
therefore winning the belle of for
Camelot sighs standing over 70 to 80
feet tall and with a length maybe twice
or three times its height this
transformer dragon has a wingspan that
is maybe 300 feet from tip to tip
destruction being a transformer and more
than that a combination of 12 immensely
powerful transformer knights dragon
storm can destroy anything in his path
and its unique metallic body can
withstand shock and damage that can be
otherwise wound other dragons in this
list killcount dragon storm has been in
countless battles before his time on
earth but in the last night movie he was
seen winning the battle for Camelot
therefore killing hundreds of Saxon
warriors he is also credited with
killing several Decepticons in a final
battle over earth battles this dragon is
one of the only dragons in this list
that has had balance with non-human
combatants and that as he has faced
opponents that are vastly more powerful
than soldiers armed with salts or even
modern weaponry he has never been
defeated in battle and has killed
Decepticons and even tackling down the
mighty infernicus on the number-two spot
comes the emoji from the South Korean
movie dragon wars are also called D Wars
the emoji is a serpent like proto dragon
from the South Korean movie dragon wars
the legend says that every five hundred
years in return of benefits and kindness
that an emoji which is a giant serpent
like dragon will be provided to humanity
and the emoji will be bestowed by a yogi
a source of untold power that would
transform him into a celestial dragon in
the movie there are two of these the
good one which is our choice for the
list and the bad one also called the
baracci
sighs both de mogi in the movie are
around a hundred meters or more in
length as seen when the barak II was
circling around a skyscraper and then as
a celestial dragon the good one retained
the same size but with more power and
divinity destruction the good emoji is
one of the only dragons in this list
that although half the power and the
ability to cause immense damage and
destruction chooses not to kill count
the only dragon in this list is the good
emoji with a zero kill count of humans
and one kill against the bat emoji kagu
rocky
battles
this is the second dragon to battle
other large monsters
the good emoji battle against Ibaraki
and was almost killed but was revived
when the woman transferred the magical
yeoju onto him therefore transforming
him into a celestial dragon and winning
him the fight and the number one spot
goes to de Gaara from the rebirth of
Matra to the Gaara is an aquatic reptile
that possesses characteristics of both a
manta ray and a dragon he has tree horns
on his head in a triangular arc and he
has two cannon like structures on his
shoulders I can split open when he
releases the baram's negara has two
wings but they are folded when he is on
nan but when the gaara's fly's wings
unfold about to half his body length
size this dragon kaiju is gigantic in
size and way bigger than other dragons
seen in fiction his total length is 73
meters which is around 2 and 40 feet
long his wingspan is 36 meters or 120
feet wide and he weighs around 17,000
700 tons
destruction thousands of years after his
creation and hibernation the Gaara was
awakened again due to the rise of
pollution rates in Japan it began eating
the pollution and releasing the baram's
once again the baram's attacked and
killed many people on the surface kill
count not much is known about a skill
count except for the fact that he
destroyed an ancient civilization called
the nilai kanai so we can say that the
death toll that he causes to the ancient
civilization ranges from hundreds of
thousands to millions barrels the Gaara
was unbeatable by humanity's weapons and
was able to withstand direct blows from
all types of firepower he was also able
to best Mothra leo in underwater battle
until it transformed into aqua mantra
and defeated Negara
so do like share and subscribe for more
related content on monsters guide use
and more also hit that notification bell
in fact smash it so you can get regular
and actual notifications